[Musique]
je te demandais pas grand chose
sincèrement je voulais simplement avoir
une vie normale ou la wii stop stop stop
ça oui mais elle est morte avant
d'arriver au bloc
[Musique]
le sort était très malade dans la
voiture elle avait toujours peur qu'il
m'arrive un truc
l'autre soir dans sa voiture j'étais
contente qu'elle soit morte
on se réveille ça va tout va bien et un
truc qui tourne pas rond chez moi vous
vous êtes jetés sur un policier voulu
relier comme une malade mentale
elles laissent des messages sur mon
répondeur j'aimerai tellement oublier
tout ça
mais le monde empêche
[Musique]
et la vôtre mortel est toujours là
est ce que tu veux tu veux mener une vie
normale
pour ça il faut que tu sois en sécurité
je vous trouverez tu passes ton temps à
refouler sa mort depuis que je te
connais gessier morte je ne refuse rien
tu te rends compte de ce que tu viens de
me sortir qu'il n'a jamais supporté ce
qu'ils nous ont fait
[Musique]